pour la quatrième fois de l'année
scolaire les élèves ont donc été privés
d'école ce mardi une journée de grève et
de manifestations à l'appel des cinq
fédérations de l'enseignement budget
retraite décentralisation les motifs
d'inquiétude sont nombreux
bilan de cette journée une mobilisation
stable voire un petit peu en baisse chez
les enseignants par rapport aux
mouvements précédents en baisse plus
clair chez le reste des personnels selon
le ministère reportage de claude gilbert
et de jean jacques botti
luc ferry ministre de l'éducation et
cible des enseignants en grève
aujourd'hui dans la rue dans le projet
du gouvernement pour l'éducation
nationale suppressions de postes réforme
des retraites et décentralisation de
100000 personnels non enseignants les
manifestants dénoncent la fin de
l'égalité tasse à l'éducation pour les
enseignants pour l'ensemble des
personnels mais aussi risque pour le
l'avenir dès élèves parce que dans un
système éclatèrent on aura un système
plus inégalitaire c'est une autre école
qui se dessine une école - démocratique
une école différente une école roupiller
qu'hier au bout du compte ce sera pour
ceux qui sont les plus favorisés
suppression de 5600 postes de
surveillants et de 20000 postes
d'éducateurs probable baisse des
recrutements d'enseignants en 2004 selon
les profs en colère le budget en baisse
annonce aussi une chute de la qualité de
l'enseignement prédication
au rabais c'est à dire qu'on mettra
moins d'argent pour l'éducation et
peut-être qu'à long terme plus d'argent
pour les prisons voilà alors est-ce
qu'on veut ça je pense quoi les
enseignants se sentent aussi menacée par
la réforme générale des retraites une
forte baisse du niveau de vie des
retraités s'ajouterait à l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation à 40 puis 42
années voire plus si on fait des faibles
et des lacs le travail jusqu'à 42
annuités mata va dire qu'on fera des
coureurs à des élèves quand on sera un
axe trust annoncé pour les faire bien et
est ce que c'est valade d'avoir un
professeur de soi confié dans une classe
ensuite ac sur les retraites cheval de
bataille commun à tous les salariés
touchés par la réforme raffarin les
20000 manifestants qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui à paris reviendront mardi
prochain pour la journée de grève
générale de la fonction publique